chers amis je voudrais d'abord vous
remercier remercier du fond du coeur
tout les adhérents qui sont dans l'autre
salle qui n'ont pas pu rentrer dans
celle ci
l'autre salle qui bondit aussi et vous
adresser à tous dans cette salle et dans
l'autre tous mes voeux tous nos voeux
nos remerciements pour votre venue votre
adhésion vous dire combien je suis
heureux d'avoir à mes côtés une équipe
de cette qualité
entraîné par notre secrétaire général
eric woerth pour qui j'ai beaucoup
d'amitié
il me permettra aussi beaucoup
d'admiration parce que c'est un homme
qui a eu à affronter
lavillénie la politique c'est une chose
la qualité humaine c'est aussi une chose
et quand les deux se rencontrent ça fait
un bon secrétaire général des
républicains mes chers amis en ce début
d'année c'est sans doute le moment de
faire le point sur l'année dernière et
sur ce qui va se passer cette année
l'année 2015 a été une année bien
chargée
j'avais pris un certain nombre
d'engagements et je crois que c'est le
moment de faire le point
lorsque je suis revenu dans la vie
politique je l'ait annoncé en septembre
gd lui à la fin novembre 2014
j'avais dit il faut tout changer dans
notre famille il faut qu'on rassemble
qu'on reconstruise et qu'on affronte les
élections en 2015 j'ai eu trois
élections affronter l'élection interne
où j'ai pu être élu président de l'ump à
l'époque avec 65 % des suffrages au
premier tour
merci ce qui a unanimement été décrit
comme un score extrêmement décevant
naturellement
c'est pas terrible au premier tour 65 %
bien sûr oui on sait bien sûr l'élection
s'est passée dans des conditions dignes
sans aucune contestation possible
hommage soit rendu à mes concurrents
bruno le maire et avait marie-do à ce
moment là je vous ai dit on va changer
les statuts on va changer de nom
on va changer notre façon de faire la
politique entre temps il nous fallait
gagner le premier scrutin le scrutin
départemental l'ensemble des
observateurs nous indiquait que ce
serait des élections très difficile et
que le front national gagnerait pas
moins d'une dizaine de départements
nous avons été à ces élections
nous avons remporté les trois quarts des
départements français le front national
n'a remporté aucun et dans 98% des cas
nous avons présenté des candidats
uniques de l'opposition républicaine
j'ai estimé que c'était vraiment pas le
moment de donner le sentiment de la
division ce résultat fut à juste titre
attribué au collectif
tout le monde sait ici que l'échec est
enfin que la victoire est collective
puis j'ai proposé que nous changions le
nombre d'autres formations politiques
c'était pas pour faire un artefact de
communication c'est parce que je pensais
que la situation de notre pays j'y
reviendrai était si grave qu'il fallait
que nous nous dotions d'un symbole et
d'un nom et nous mêmes qui répondent à
la priorité qui était la nôtre
quelle est cette priorité que la
république me recule bleus j'ai donc
proposé que nous nous appelons les
républicains n'ont pas que les autres ne
soient pas républicain mais nous sommes
les seuls à mettre la république devant
tous je ne conteste nullement aux
socialistes d'être des républicains mais
sont socialistes avant d'être
républicain nous sommes républicains
parce que nous ne voulons plus que la
république
aucune grande les bars
j'ai lu tous les commentaires à l'époque
tout le monde était contre aujourd'hui
tout le monde est pour le nouveau nom
s'est installé très facilement et je
tiens à rendre hommage au travail
efficace du parti socialiste qui en nous
faisant un procès a conduit assez
rapidement à la notoriété de notre
nouvelle dénomination
c'est une aide sur laquelle je ne
comptais pas mais au fond
après tout tous les soutiens sont
bienvenus et grâce à eux
en quinze jours on avait oublié l'ump
nous étions les républicains et nous
sommes à peu près le seul pays au monde
où la majorité socialiste entendait
choisir la dénomination de l'opposition
républicaine
les événements nous ont donné raison
les événements dramatiques qu'a connue
notre pays nous nous appelons les
républicains après les événements de
2000 15 janvier 2015 de novembre 2015
qui ont clairement montré que la
république était attaqué en tant que tel
et que c'est la république qui devait
apporter une réponse ferme
j'y reviendrai puis nous avons affronté
les élections régionales dans un
contexte d'une complication extrême je
rende hommage à nos candidats tous nos
candidats faire campagne alors que la
france avait connu 132 où 133 morts
alors que la france était traumatisée
par les événements de janvier et par les
événements de novembre
maintenir une campagne s'était pas sain
c'était d'une complication extrême parce
qu'il fallait être digne et en même
temps porter nos idées
j'ai rarement connu une campagne aussi
difficile à mener
nous avions une région nous en avions
lui nous en avons 8
nous avons multiplié par 8
notre score ce fut une année mans décrit
comme un échec
c'est pas simplement que nous avions
perdu c'est vrai passé de une à huit
alors dans le même temps l'été passé 21
régions à presse et dans les victoires
on a eu deux magnifiques succès entre
autres de la région parisienne avec
valérie pécresse qui a fait une campagne
remarquable
et de ronald gouvernent ou notre
vice-président laurent wauquiez dans une
région très difficile a fait un score
lui aussi remarquable nous avons gagné
60% des régions d'ongles les deux
peuples et ça n'a pas empêché un
hebdomadaire extrêmement avisé expliqué
que j'avais perdu les élections
la couverture de l'hebdomadaire passera
vite la victoire aux élections
régionales elle reste c'était un combat
très difficile qui m'a amené à prendre
des décisions
l'aude puis ce que j'affirme que nous ne
ferons jamais un accord avec le front
national et que nous ne voulons pas
aider ceux qui font monter le front
national par une politique
invraisemblable que subliminal les
observateurs ont rendu hommage aux
socialistes d'avoir retiré leur candidat
dans deux régions oubliant de préciser
que s'il l'avait retiré c'est parce que
les scores du premier tour avait été si
faible dans des régions il était beau
même sortant quand on fait 18% au
premier tout 16% au premier tour dans
des régions qu'on dirige depuis des
années et des années
ça montre que s'ils n'ont pas été
présents au second tour c'est parce
qu'ils avaient subi le désaveu des
électeurs de cette région je pense au
nord pas de calais picardie mon générer
et je pense à la région paca où nous
avons le succès de christian estrosi et
xavier bertrand et puis à la fin de
l'année on a eu à faire le bilan du
fonctionnement du parti qui est le nôtre
heureusement que le parti va mal parce
que qu'est ce que ça serait si elle est
bien
à titre d'exemple j'ai dû autorisé le
précédent directeur général frédéric
péchenard à maintenir la maison ouverte
dimanche à distribuer des heures
supplémentaires tellement nous étions
submergés par les adhésions depuis la
mi-décembre sommes passés un rite de
1000 à 2000 par jour ne même fait un
jour à 6000 j'ai demandé à ce qu'un
huissier viennent je ne veux pas de
contestation et nous sommes pratiquement
240 milles soit 26 milles de plus que
lundi à dire à l'époque où j'étais déjà
président et où il y avait eu une
élection interne et c'est donc pour nous
un encouragement à continuer et
naturellement aller beaucoup plus loin
encore je vous avais promis que vous
mettriez vautier votre réel sur le les
éléments du programme
c'est ce que nous avons fait chaque
consultation sur le projet nous avons eu
entre 40000 et 60000 vote et j'ai lancé
les élections dans notre formation
politique pour janvier partout en france
vous allez élire vos délégués de
circonscription vos présidents de
fédérations vous allez voter et je
réunirai les 13 et 14 février un conseil
national qui procédera à l'élection de
deux nouveaux bureaux politiques et des
nouveaux présidents du conseil national
bref comme je m'étais engagé vous votez
sur les hommes et les femmes qui vous
conduisent et vous votez également sur
les éléments du projet vous savez je
peux regarder bien dans les yeux chacun
d'entre vous j'ai essayé de tenir tous
les engagements que nous avions pris
tous
je veux m'expliquer sur une chose qui
peut être a surpris désappointé ou déçu
certains d'entre vous quand je suis
revenu la profondeur de la crise que
traversait notre parti politique était
telle que je n'ai eu qu'une seule
priorité celle de rassembler d'apaiser
de cautériser c'était dans un délai d'un
an les haines les oppositions étaient si
fortes que si j'appuie est trop fort sur
l'accélérateur
ça pouvait céder la maison était si
fragile rassembler faire venir chacun
organisé les bureaux politiques chercher
des compromis apaisée a été mon travail
de 7,2 l'année dernière d'autant plus
qu'avec les deux scrutins
c'était vraiment pas le moment que nous
nous divisions au sommet je ne dis pas
que je fus parfait je ne dis pas que
l'entente est en tout point
épanouissante
mais enfin là où un grand nombre d'entre
vous se demandent s il y avait une
opposition
vous vous demandez plus une opposition
l'opposition est là et l'opposition
c'est nous voilà là elle est
incontournable
ça m'a amené à ne pas tout entendre à ne
pas tout voir
plus difficile encore à ne pas tout
comprendre
je les fais dans l'intérêt de notre
famille politique est derrière
dans notre pays nous arrivons dans une
autre phase ce devoir de rassemblement
est devenu pour moi un devoir de clarté
et ça m'a amené dès le début de l'année
à composer une nouvelle équipe je ferai
d'autres domination dans les jours qui
viennent mais j'ai considéré que devant
la gravité de la situation de la france
la complexité de ce qui nous aide qui
nous attendait l'exigence de clarté de
nos compatriotes en général et de vous
en particulier que je me devais de
construire de constituer une équipe
certes de rassembler mais cohérente car
vous ne supportez plus les déclarations
personnelles de tel ou tel qui ne
correspondent en rien à ce que vous
attendez à ce que vous pensez
chacun dans le mouvement est libre de
dire ce qu'il veut mais quand on est
dans la direction du mouvement
on ne peut pas défendre des idées qui ne
correspondent en rien à ce que pense la
majorité des adhérents du mouvement
quel sera notre priorité pour 2016 2016
est une année où il n'y a pas d'élection
c'est donc une année qui doit être
consacrée au travail de fond au projet à
la clarté de nos engagements pour
l'avenir et à la préparation de
l'alternance
qu'est ce qui s'est passé aux régionales
une immense inquiétude de nos
compatriotes inquiétudes sur quoi sur la
france et sur sa pérennité
les français ont reçu de leurs
grands-parents et leurs parents un mode
de vie une culture un pays des terroirs
une façon de faire et les français nous
disent nous voulons transmettre à nos
enfants ce que nos parents nous ont
transmis
nous voulons pas renoncer à notre langue
à notre mode de vie à notre culture à
notre pays à notre époux nicolas lesage
il est là n'est pas ailleurs c'est celui
là et c'est la réponse que nous devons
apporter
j'ai voulu que nous organisions les
primaires le calendrier fixé septembre
novembre les moyens pour cette primaire
ont été dégagés en autofinancement sans
un seul emprunt de plus uniquement dans
les économies que nous avons réalisés et
les adhérents qui nous ont rejoints
c'est fait il y aura donc compétition
c'est bien elle se fera au moment où il
a été décidé
personne n'en être inquiété mais le
mouvement politique est le nôtre va
devoir consacrer les neuf fois d'ici aux
primaires à définir des lignes force
d'un projet politique d'une force comme
jamais parce que c'est ce que les
français attendent de nous la question
n'est pas de se lancer dans un concours
de beauté pour savoir tel ou tel
maintenant la question c'est est ce que
les républicains sont à même où non de
proposer une alternance franche forte à
une france inquiète sur son devenir
entre des socialistes qui nous ont
conduits là où nous sommes et un front
national qui nous conduirait dans une
situation qui serait notre pays ce que
nous voulons aucun prix l'alternance
reposant uniquement sur nos épaules
nous devons faire ce travail en
profondeur de clarté
ce qui va m'amener ça me fait plaisir de
retrouver dia
on est et m'a dit est ce qu'on voulait
qu'on prépare un discours non laisse
tomber ça va discours il est dans mon
coeur
accessoirement dans ma tête ce qui va
donc maintenir à organiser à porter a
suscité des débats sur des choses
absolument essentiel que nous devront
trancher sans ambiguïté y compris si ça
doit conduire avoir une majorité dans la
famille minorité dans l'année je veux
dire que la question de notre rapport à
la nation doit être posée avec franchise
il ya ceux dont je suis qui pensent que
la france c'est pas fini eh bien nous
avons nous devront l'assumer et en tirer
des conséquences
il ya des questions comme les frontières
qui ne sont pas des gros mots est-ce que
la frontière est compatible avec
l'europe
j'ai toujours été européen mais je dis
si l'europe n'est pas capable de se
doter de frontières en elle-même nous
devons poser la question de la défense
de nos frontières nous mêmes il ya la
question des transferts de souveraineté
il ya la question de la réalité du
programme économique et du choc fiscal
aux chances de la baisse des impôts que
nous devons porter il ya la question
centrale cher eric de l'intégration et
de l'assimilation jeudi que
l'intégration est insuffisante
il faut maintenant on s'assimile parce
que c'est au dernier arrivé d'accepter
de s'intégrer dans la culture elle note
de vie de ceux qui sont déjà là ce qui
me gêne
il ya la question de l'innovation hier
la question la sécurité nous ces débats
nous allons les menées avec le souci de
la transparence
ce qui n'empêchera nullement le débat
des présidentielles le moment venu je
rappelle que habitants dans la même
famille politique on doit quand même
avoir des points communs je peux répéter
si vous voulez de rire ça m'amène à vous
dire un mot d'un sujet très important et
d'actualité
vous savez vous connaissez le meilleur
conseiller en communication qui ait
jamais existé dans le monde
boileau ce qui se conçoit bien s'énonce
clairement et les mots pour le dire
viennent aisément
je veux parler de la question de la
double nationalité et de retrait de la
nationalité
avec d'autres ici nous pensons que quand
on a la double nationalité etc ont trahi
la france en prenant les armes contre la
france en prenant les armes contre les
français en s'associant au jihad et aux
terroristes comme on a trahi la france
on ne mérite plus d'être français voilà
ce que je france j'ai toujours répondu
privé et je continuerai à la victoire
dans le discours de grenoble fameux et
qui paraît tellement d'actualité et en
même temps tellement modéré bras parce
qu'on entend aujourd'hui mon dieu que
tous ceux qui se sont émus et à qui on a
présenté des sels pour qu'ils ne tombent
pas évanouie du discours de grenoble
faut qu'on y aille ou krieg avec ce
qu'ils entendent aujourd'hui j'ai donc
manifester mon soutien au retrait de la
nationalité pour les français
binationaux qui trahissent la france
c'est mon engagement et que personne n'a
tente de nous en général est bon en
particulier que je renonçais cette
conviction au prétexte que c'est le
président hollande qui la propose parce
que mes chers amis si je renonçais à
cette conviction au prétexte qu'elle est
portée par françois hollande
cela voudrait dire que je préfère la
politique politicienne à la sécurité des
français
ce serait indigne d'un ancien président
de la république et du président des
particuliers
indigne la question n'est donc pas comme
gens t'entendent observateurs comment
voulez-vous voter une réforme proposée
par hollande
la question est ce que cette réforme
servira la sécurité des français ou pas
si elle sert la sécurité des français
nous la ferons parce que c'est notre
devoir et si on ne fait pas comme ça
c'est qu'on n'aime pas la france et
qu'on mérite pas d'avoir les
responsabilités auxquelles les uns et
les autres nous postulants j'ajoute une
chose j'ai été amené au nom du bureau
politique qui en a décidé un immense
majorité a formulé un certain nombre de
demandes certains indices et des
conditions non je veux être sûr qu'on ne
ment pas aux français si françois
hollande veut la déchéance de
nationalité pour les binationaux
je réitère qu'il s'agit bien d'une
déchéance de nationalité et ne pas d'un
artifice de communication en
commanditant de triangulation pour la
réforme de la constitution françois
hollande propose l'article 34 parfait
l'article 34 prévoient qu'il faut une
loi organique d'exécution après la
réforme de la constitution
j'estime que nous sommes en droit de
demander à connaître la loi d'exécution
en même temps que nous votons le
principe du retrait de la nationalité
ce n'est pas une condition c'est
simplement une affaire de bon sens sinon
nous risquons poté un principe est
d'avoir une loi d'exécution soit qu'ils
n'arrivent pas toi qui dit le contraire
du principe je voudrais d'ailleurs dire
que je suis très étonné de ce qui se
passe je me fais de procès d'intention à
personne mais si j'ai compris à peu près
ce qui se passe on a donc françois
hollande qui a changé du tout au tout sa
position sur le retrait de la
nationalité ça peut arriver qu'ils
demandent à la garde des sceaux de
porter un projet de réforme de la
constitution ce qui n'est pas rien j'ai
fait une réforme de la constitution en
2008 la ministre que françois hollande
choisi pour porter cette réforme répète
matin midi et soir qu'elle est opposée à
la réforme qu'elle va devoir présenter
je sais pas qu il faut siffler mais
imaginez que moi président de la
république j'ai fait la même chose
je voudrais maintenant sur le fond dire
deux trois choses parce qu'elle me
semblent importantes
on me dit oh le retrait de la
nationalité ce n'est qu'un symbole
ça sert à rien d'abord c'est bien la
première fois que j'entends dire que
dans la république les symboles ne sert
à rien parce que si les symboles ne
servent à rien on se demande pourquoi un
drapeau on se demande pourquoi on anime
on demande pourquoi on fait défiler le
14 juillet on se demande pourquoi on a
des mariannes dans nos mairies on se
demande pourquoi on a liberté égalité
fraternité
une devise républicaine la république ce
sont des symboles est justement ce qui
manque notamment dans l'école de la
république c'est l'absence totale de
symbole c'est un symbole très utile à
mes yeux que quand les enfants sont dans
une classe et que lemaitre entre dans la
classe les enfants se relève
c'est un symbole très utile à mes yeux
que quand on rentre en classe on ne
porte pas de casquette c'est un symbole
très utile à mes yeux quand j'ai proposé
que soit voté l'interdiction du port de
la burqa c'est un symbole très utile
qu'on interdise le voile ou qui cher et
je pourrais multiplier les exemples de
symboles ou attendus où at-on vu que les
symboles ne servait à rien et vous mes
chers amis
père mère de famille éducateurs vous
pensez que dans le rapport avec vos
enfants les symboles ça ne signifie rien
et quand on perd quelqu'un ça ne
signifie rien le symbole de se
rassembler tous ensemble ça n'ont qu'une
signification
justement nous sommes devenus nous les
êtres humains nous avons construit une
civilisation qu'est ce que c'est la
civilisation si ce n'est une addition de
symboles qu'on doit respecter qu'on doit
chérir qui ne sont pas inutiles tournait
pas de la marchandisation
tout n'est pas une équation de plus de
4,4
tout n'est pas avec une valeur marchande
il ya des symboles qui nous dépasse il
ya la patrie
il ya l'amour qu'on a pour son pays il
ya les monuments aux morts qui ne sont
pas des symboles qui sont simplement la
reconnaissance qu'on doit à des femmes
et des hommes qui sont morts pour qu'on
soit libre tout ça ça compte quand même
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
de symboles qui ne servent à rien je
vois qu'on est dans l'harmonie bon enfin
par moment d'entendre ces choses que on
se sent seul c'est pour ça que c'est
bien qu'on se retrouvent le samedi
j'ajoute une deuxième chose que c'est
une erreur totale de dire que le retrait
de la nationalité ne servent à rien
pourquoi parce que c'est une demande que
nous avons présentées dans mon esprit un
binational qui trahit la france pour
activités terroristes doit se retrouvent
recevoir retirer sa nationalité et être
expulsé manu militari
une fois sa peine de prison exécuté
c'est pas simplement pour dire qu'on lui
retire la nationalité ce qui évite le
parcours du combattant de l'expulsion
sur un droit de l'expulsion que plus
personne ne comprend et on va mettre dix
ans avant d'expulser quelqu'un dont on
ne veut plus sur le territoire de la
république parce qu'il a trahi la
république
on me dit enfin ah oui mais il n'ya plus
en plus de binationaux c'est une insulte
pour les binationaux
mais quelle est cette façon de réfléchir
la question n'est pas le montrer du
doigt les pies nationaux la question
c'est de montrer du doigt les
terroristes ça n'a aucun sens de la même
façon que nous n'acceptons pas
l'amalgamme naturellement sur le
compatriote d'origine musulmane ou de
culture ou de confession musulmane mais
nous jouerons pas mettre l'amalgamme sur
les binationaux
nous parlons bien des terroristes pas
débit
nationaux on me dit ah oui mais il faut
le mec aussi pour les nationaux comme
dans ma vie j'en ai entendu des bêtises
mais alors là là on franchit toutes les
barrières
pourquoi pourquoi voulez vous qu'on
retire la nationalité à un français
parce qu'il est convaincu d'activités
terroristes
et comme il n'a pas d'autres
nationalités sera patrick dont on pourra
le garder je vois vraiment pas en quoi
on aurait résolu le problème
j'ai pris du temps pour vous expliquer
cette poutre notre position pour
comprendre que c'est notre position et
que je n'ai pas l'intention qu'on y
aille en s'excusant au prétexte que
c'est porté par françois hollande
parce que pour nous attaché comme nous
le sommes à la france les choix que nous
faisons doit être guidée par l'intérêt
des français par la sécurité des
français et non pas par des arrières
pensées politiciennes
enfin je voudrais dire un mot de de
l'équipe
titi qui m'entoure je vous ai parlé de
laurent wauquiez qui a mené un combat
formidable qui est à nos jeunes espoirs
je vous ai parlé d' eric woerth
je voudrais vous présenter ce qu'ils ont
dit si eric ciotti qui acceptent de
prendre les fédérations mai
je lui ai bien dit que dans mon esprit
ça ne voulait pas dire qu'ils arrêtent
de prendre la parole sur les thèmes qui
lui sont chers
j'évolue également deux nouveaux porte
parole non pas que les autres avaient
les présidents ait démérité bien au
contraire
bien au contraire n'est ce pas sébastien
qui pondent hautes responsabilités mais
parce que ça correspond à une nouvelle
période de l'activité de notre mouvement
j'ai voulu donner leur chance et leur
exposition médiatique
d'abord à deux jeunes parce que on me
dit souvent le renouvellement oui
renouvellement pour moi c'est celui qui
a beaucoup d'énergie et j'ai trouvé
qu'en choisissant guillaume larrivé et
guillaume pelletier
je vous donnais deux porte parole de
grande qualité
le droit d'ailleurs je dois d'ailleurs
dire un mot particulier à guillaume
pelletier parce que hélas à ma demande
avec beaucoup de d'élégance renoncer à
être tête de liste dans sa région
je le remercie beaucoup parce que vous
savez quand j'ai voulu l'accord avec
l'ue dei
il n'y a pas d'accord où on aurait
toutes les têtes de listes non guillaume
aurait parfaitement pu postuler poids
tête de liste il a joué le jeu et en
cela elle a montré qu il avait pris en
maturité et guillaume pelletier idiome
l'arrivée j'ai pas fait c'est pas fait
exprès qu'ils aident même prénom va
falloir ranger sa sont vraiment deux
espoirs dans notre famille politique
j'ai demandé également à brigitte
dussert d'être porte parole
le président très important pour moi
elle est maire du xviie arrondissement
qui est une des d un des arrondissements
les plus peuplés de paris je les ai
observés prendre la parole plusieurs
fois et je trouve qu'elle donne de notre
formation politique
l'image à la fois apaisé et forte
et j'aime bien cette idée en plus
valérie de bord mais j'aime bien cette
idée qu'on a essayé ces quatre personnes
ensemble pour porter la parole de de
notre mouvement
gène autres nommés également sébastien
comme secrétaire général adjoint
sébastien est un homme du nord alain
joyandet comme conseiller politique
alain aussi je lui dois beaucoup
parce que dans sa région il aurait pu
postuler lui aussi est tête de liste
c'est un homme loyal et vous savez la
fidélité n'est pas une valeur démodé
c'est parfois on me dit ah oui intel
avec ce que tu as fait pour lui moi je
suis toujours tourné vers l'avenir
j'attache pas beaucoup d'importance à
tout ça mais la fidélité
les gens qui sont capables de garder une
ligne des gens qui dans la tempête sont
capables de résister à la tentation
d'aller à gauche à droite partout des
gens qui sont capables de rester fidèle
non pour la peine de nude et non tout le
monde les connaît c'est pareil je
voudrais remercier alain joyandet
également pierre charon qui m'accompagne
le sénateur de paris
depuis si longtemps qui aura bien sûr
des responsabilités on résumer cette
année 2016 on entame avec enthousiasme
je vous promets des événements
intéressants
je vous promet beaucoup de passion mais
surtout ce que je voudrais que vous
compreniez c'est pour nous le fil
conducteur de tout ceci c'est la france
l'amour qu'on a pour la france
l'amour qu'on doit la france au fond
bien sûr si on fait de la politique y
compris quand vous même vous venez pour
participer à une réunion pour prendre la
carte d'un parti politique bien sûr qui
a parfois des ambitions des uns les
autres et alors quelle est l'ambition
collective d'un pays si y'a pas
d'ambitions individuelles mais un fil
conducteur entre nous c'est qu'au-delà
de nos familles au delà de nos vies
personnelles
au delà de nos vies professionnelles il
ya en france il ya le fait qu'on ne peut
pas supporter l'affaissement de la
france qu'on ne peut pas supporter le
déclassement de la france et qu'on a
envie de servir la france est au fond
vous nous rejoignez cette année 2016
tellement importante puisqu'elle précède
l'année 2017 ou à vraiment se passer
quelque chose
vous rendez compte qu'on a un an et demi
pour porter un combat pour conduire un
combat aussi important que celui que
nous sommes les seuls à pouvoir assumer
préparer et conduire l'alternance c'est
pas rien c'est passionnant
donc j'ai besoin que vous engagiez de
toutes vos forces
coface y venir d'autres personnes que
vous soyez les plus nombreux possibles à
vous engager
qu'en disent est ce que vous souhaitez
ce que vous voulez que vous participiez
aux élections notre mouvement au débat
dans notre mouvement que vous compreniez
que ce qui nous rassemble est tellement
plus important que tous les petits
soucis du quotidien
puis je voudrais corps portant vous
n'ayez pas de doute
j'aime tellement ce que je fais j'ai
tellement envie
mes chers amis bonne année à tous et
soyez assurés que 2016 ne va pas vous
décevoir
j'aurais plaisir à continuer à discuter
avec vous merci